for a long time there's been sort of a a
jokey question among pet owners you may
have heard this where they wonder if you
died at home alone would your cats eat
you this is something this is something
cat owners actually don't be
enthusiastic about it creep over here
it's in his will he wants to be eaten up
no it's a thing would you would your cat
eat you well according to this study
reported on by the Washington Post it
turns out they might this is true yes
this is true and this has caused a lot
of cat owners to take some serious
measures to protect themselves like this
okay okay I think everything is in order
my client is ready to sign this contract
if there's nothing else my client will
agree not to eat your clients corpse but
would like to reserve the right to lick
and nibble at her dead body following a
two-day grace period okay I think that's
acceptable to my client if your client
agrees to limit all nibbling to the body
while avoiding my clients face
I think we have a deal
[Music]
good job
you